[Musica]
arthur rubinstein un grande pianista
[Applauso]
[Musica]
george enescu un violinista dalle doti
eccezionali
[Musica]
[Risate]
è la meravigliosa voce di maria callas
tre grandi solisti tre grandi esibizioni
ma cosa succede se proviamo per un
attimo a immaginare di mischiarli
insieme senza alcun criterio
[Musica]
un disastro del resto i musicisti
conoscono bene il concetto di armonia
ogni nota ogni suono ma anche ogni pausa
deve essere armonicamente connessa ai
suoni alle pause degli altri esecutori
se si vuole ottenere un grande risultato
ecco un grande risultato non soltanto in
musica un concetto del quale tenere
conto in generale 20 giugno 2012
una data che ha segnato una svolta
importante nel mio cammino di vita
quel giorno alla mia bimba di soli 8
anni venne diagnosticata la retinite
pigmentosa sale e pepe il nome
lascerebbe evocare una scampagnata con
carne e salsiccia sale pepe
in realtà parliamo di una patologia rara
una malattia genetica
una malattia che porta chi ne è affetto
nella migliore delle ipotesi è una
perdita grave del visus che si fa in
questi casi si abbandona allo sconforto
alla disperazione
oppure si cerca di afferrare il toro per
le corna
la prima reazione istintiva fu quella di
prendere un foglio di carta e cominciare
a buttar giù degli appunti delle idee
poi diventate in realtà delle tesi di
laurea per studenti che man mano me ne
facessero richiesta
aventi come obiettivo quello di
trasformare questo oggetto uno
smartphone
ce lo portiamo dietro quasi fosse
un'appendice del nostro corpo e spesso
li facciamo fare cose anche abbastanza
stupida come postare una foto del piatto
che stiamo per mangiare sui social
ridare dignità potrei dire a questo
oggetto tramite delle tesi che avevano
come obiettivo quello di trasformarlo in
un ausilio per persone con disabilità
visiva uno strumento che li potesse
accompagnare nel quotidiano
è così che nacque il progetto di ice i
ragazzi erano molto contenti entusiasti
le loro tesi erano non più soltanto un
modo per arrivare all'obiettivo tanto
sognato la laurea ma anche qualcosa da
spendere nel sociale sentivo però che
qualcosa non mi quadrava non mi tornava
non riuscivo a capire bene cosa fosse
capito dove stava il problema
io in realtà non avevo la minima idea di
cosa significasse vivere con la retinite
pigmentosa cosa significasse non
beneficiare del senso della vista non
vedere sapere di dover diventare non
vedente e soprattutto non sapevo nemmeno
cosa potesse dal punto di vista
tecnologico essere utile realizzare
fu così che cominciai allora a ad
affrontare un periodo abbastanza lungo
vivendo a contatto con chi ha nel
quotidiano questa condizione con chi ha
questa malattia con chi le ha perso la
vista con chi ha bisogno che gli venga
davvero sviluppato qualcosa di utile
è questo lungo periodo ha portato a
delle considerazioni che ho riassunto in
tre punti anche se sono molto più
complessi probabilmente il primo gli
ausili esistenti il tipo tecnologico
ovviamente sono basati su sistemi chiusi
tecnologie proprietarie non modificabili
non personalizzabili
questa considerazione parte da un errore
di fondo che è quello di considerare il
non vedente come una entità universale
uguale qualunque sia l'individuo
qualunque sia il vissuto in realtà noi
potremmo prendere dieci cento mille non
vedenti avremmo dieci cento mille
esigenze differenti
chi è nato non vedente avrà esigenze
differenti da chi l'ha vista
l'ha persa nel tempo ma ne ha
beneficiato per qualche anno per quanti
anni ne avrà beneficiato farà sì che se
avranno individui differenti con
differenti esigenze così come aver perso
la vista in modo rapido e repentino con
un trauma un incidente farà sì che si
abbia un soggetto con esigenze
differenti da chi l'ha vista la persa
con una malattia come queste nel tempo
negli anni con un aspetto degenerativo
il secondo aspetto il costo gli ausili
tecnologici hanno un costo esorbitante
non tocca mentre l'area nel merito sia
ben chiaro non è questa la mia
intenzione però è un paradosso un
ausilio un oggetto che per definizione
deve rendere accessibile un'azione
quotidiana che però non è accessibile
dal punto di vista dei costi
assurdo è come se io mi mettesse in
testa di voler risolvere il problema
della fame nel mondo e andasse in giro
box o in africa con la camionetta a
vendere panini a 100 euro l'uno il
concetto è lo stesso se ci ragioniamo
l'ultima considerazione è più di tipo
tecnologica chi produce ausili per
disabili visivi sempre di tipo
tecnologico naturalmente pensa che la
sintesi vocale sia la panacea per tutti
i mali
fateci caso tutti gli ausili tecnologici
per non vedenti costringono quel povero
non vedente andarsene in giro con
qualcuno che gli parla sempre dietro fai
questo fai quello ai quali su vai giù a
destra
un incubo che ha moglie magari può
capire cosa significhi andare dietro con
questa voce continua vedo anche mia
moglie che ride tra l'altro e sono
sicuro che mi sono reso nemiche tutte le
donne presenti in sala con questa
affermazione
da queste considerazioni ma anche da
altre è nata la mission principale di
via ice in realtà sono diventate tante
negli altri ma questa rimane la più
importante realizzare
l'alternativa open al mercato degli
ausili per persone con disabilità visiva
alternativa open che significa open
soprattutto in un contesto tecnologico
facciamo un attimo una prova quanti di
voi alzate la mano chi di voi ha uno
smartphone android
ok come direbbe tirato giù le mani
adesso
alzi la mano chi invece ha un
dispositivo con ios uno smartphone con
ios
ok con voi non parlo quindi vi inviterei
voci fuori dalla sala
scherzi a parte perché con voi non parlo
perchè a josè un sistema chiuso mentre
android è un sistema aperto che
significa significa che io esperto di
tecnologia possa entrarci dentro
posso capire come è fatto posso studiare
me lo posso modificarlo e migliorarlo
bravo al punto da realizzare una cosa
del genere
e tutto questo senza costi senza pagare
licenze senza royalty senza dover dare
conto e ragione quasi a nessuno
vedo qualcuno ancora non convinto cerco
di abbassare ancora di più il livello
della spiegazione come se dicessi da
oggi in poi potete entrare in qualsiasi
festa dice
mangiarebere a sbafo andarvene senza
pagare senza che questo costituisca né
un reato né tantomeno qualcosa di
eticamente scorretto sono certo che
questa immagine vi fa gola
ecco questo è quello che accade a noi
esperti di tecnologia ci fa gola il
fatto di entrare dentro è poter in
qualche modo capire e migliorare
contribuire la prima soluzione
tecnologica nata da questa esperienza e
la piattaforma indossabile di eyes to
wear un'infrastruttura come hardware
open source software basata su occhiali
e cintura alle mie spalle in foto vedete
un po la storia degli occhiali alla
sinistra il primo modello molto
rudimentale al centro quello che era
l'ultimo fino a poco tempo fa adesso è
diventato il penultimo perché abbiamo
scoperto che il non vedente pure piani
toso vuole sapere se sono belli che sono
eleganti se li faremo di tanti colori e
non li possiamo raccontare che sono
belli sono non vedenti ma mica stupidi
basterebbe a toccarli per capirlo quindi
stiamo concentrando sulla estetica anche
qualcosa a cui non avevamo pensato
dedicandoci soltanto la funzionalità su
questo hardware a bordo esistono dei
sensori gli occhiali e sono dotate di
una campo hi fi ad alta risoluzione
esistono degli auricolari a conduzione
ossea per beneficiare della sintesi
vocale con un approccio on demand quando
lo chiede il non vedente non imposto non
invasivo le stanghette hanno la
possibilità di vibrare separatamente
potendo beneficiare quindi di un sistema
di notifiche alternativa così come
faccio con lo smartphone quando stacco
la suoneria perché non voglio essere
disturbato non voglio disturbare non mi
interessa ricevere qualche notifica
qualche notizia sulla cintura invece la
fibbia è una particolare camera camera
la chiamerebbero gli inglesi cioè un
sensore che in grado di osservare la
scena visiva e calcolare esattamente la
distanza di ogni oggetto di ogni punto
che forma oggetto stesso rispetto al
sensore quindi rispetto a chi la indossa
su questo hardware è possibile
installare dei mattoncini come se fosse
un lego cos'è un mattoncino è un ausilio
è una funzione un modulo che permette di
far fare qualcosa questa che sia utile
un non vedente
noi abbiamo sviluppato diversi i
mattoncini abbiamo uno che inquadra del
testo e lo legge ne abbiamo un altro che
dicono soggetti che riconosce il colore
degli oggetti
abbiamo apparecchi medicali che si
connettano come uno sfigmomanometro o un
glucometro abbiamo realizzato un
mattoncino molto importante per la
mobilità qualcosa che permette di
identificare un percorso libero da
ostacoli davanti al non vedente e averlo
segnalato soltanto con la vibrazione
delle stanghette non qualcuno che gli
parla dietro costantemente come dicevamo
poc'anzi è l'ostacolo oltre a intendere
quelli tradizionali che vedete in questa
sorta di test si può intendere anche una
buca una trave altezza uomo qualcosa che
è complicato
magari andando in giro col bastone
bianco segnalare io tocco per terra e
poi ci sbattono la fronte perché non
penso a far così anche per non dare
colpi di bastone ad essere manca ma la
novità importante che questo hardware è
anche programmabile cioè chiunque abbia
le competenze per farlo può sviluppare
nuovi mattoncini può sviluppare qualcosa
al quale neanche noi abbiamo pensato una
funzione che può essere utile a un non
vedente lo stesso non vedente se esperto
di tecnologia una persona a lui cara se
lo desidera può rilasciare il mattoncino
attraverso noi attraverso uno store
dedicato che nascerà in favore di altri
che questa competenza non ce l'hanno ma
che quella funzione possono in qualche
modo aver bisogno di utilizzarla questo
è un altro concetto molto importante ma
è esportato se ci pensate anche questo
dallo smartphone
io acquisto uno smartphone che ha tanti
sensori accelerometro chip nfc belle
parole che spesso non so nemmeno cosa
significhino poi però sto dedicato mi
scarico knapp il mio telefonino per
magia diventa una bussola per scarico
un'altra e diventa un lettore di carte
di credito e pos funzioni forze alle
quali neanche chi ha rilasciato
quell'hardware aveva pensato che potesse
essere applicata allo smartphone lo
stesso quindi di ice come detto produce
tecnologia open al servizio si chiama
disabilità visiva in modo no profit
tecnologia innovativa a servizio del
sociale se ci pensate non è molto
diversa da una start up a vocazione
vocale la vocazione sociale scusate una
startup però può vendere quello che
produce può basare i profitti su questa
tecnologia
cosa ci accomuna noi e loro
questo la ricerca dei fondi soldi
benedetti soldi maledetti soldi ognuno
scelga la li na che preferisce chi sta
provando a fondare ad avviare una
startup sta bene quanto sia complesso
trovare fondi pur vendendo qualcosa
quello che un uomo russe non fa lungo
nel nostro caso non vogliamo proprio
fare oltre che non è possibile fare e la
ricerca dei fondi passa attraverso che
ne so la compilazione di format quali il
business canvas un prospetto sul quale
dimostrare un potenziale investitore che
se darà a voi i vostri soldi ne ricaverà
utili importanti rispetto a quanto possa
fare un prodotto concorrente ammesso che
esista lo smog
un altro indicatore che mi dice a
livello sistema paese quell'investimento
quanto ritornerà tutto passando
attraverso gli allievi e tropic o pc
semplicemente sapete cos'è un elevator
pitch me lo spiego in modo semplice
immaginate di trovarvi in america di
entrare alla base di una linguetta cielo
di prendere l'ascensore insieme ad un
investitore avete la botta di fortuna
fortuna con la c mi verrebbe da dire di
incontrarlo di entrarci dentro e di
averlo lì con voi non vi può scappare
finché almeno l'ascensione non porterà
al piano è in questo breve lasso di
tempo
dovete convincerlo che darvi i suoi
soldi per la vostra idea sarà la cosa
migliore che possa aver fatto nella sua
vita che gli potrebbe garantire utili
importanti adesso non so quanti di voi
sono stati mai in america con ascensore
dal piano terra
all'ottantesimo piano impiega 20 secondi
ad arrivare ma le nostre parti saremmo
più agevolati perché se prendete un
ascensore al piano terra avete la
fortuna di incontrare una ragazza un
ragazzo che vi piace e di andare solo al
quinto piano arriverete su già sposati
al di là delle semplici battute è
complesso trovare fondi anche per chi
vende qualcosa
allora cosa abbiamo pensato di fare in
realtà le tecnologie open quello che gli
esperti in economia che amerebbero
business core non è necessariamente non
deve essere anzi non lo è mai l'oggetto
che si produce la tecnologia stessa gli
occhiali nel nostro caso ma sono i
servizi accessori
la consulenza la formazione la
personalizzazione
nel nostro caso ad esempio lo sviluppo
dei mattoncini allora abbiamo pensato da
una parte ci stanno i non vedenti che
dovranno beneficiare in modo gratuito in
modo no profit degli occhiali il primo
solista per tornare all'inizio
rubinstein poi stiamo formando delle
persone degli esperti di tecnologia
affinché diventino bravi a sviluppare
nuovi mattoncini il secondo solista il
nostro violinista iniziale ma a queste
persone promettiamo anche di poter
guadagnare da questa attività per
stimolarli in qualche modo è come entra
in gioco il terzo solista la callas del
nostro esempio un ente un'associazione
qualcuno che ha un budget da utilizzare
per poter sviluppare un nuovo mattoncino
per le persone a lui care per le sugli
associati che gestisce e questo farà sì
che di ice t per a una trattativa tra lo
sviluppatore è l'ente il committente lo
chiameremmo affinché il cliente finale
non vedente possa beneficiare del
prodotto questa trattativa dovrà far
corrispondere a una percentuale alle
casse di via in modo che noi possiamo
sostenere il modello dal punto di vista
economico
possiamo sviluppare nuova tecnologia
possiamo costruire o istanze di occhiali
rilasciarle e alimentare lingotto
alimentare questo circolo
ecco questi tre solisti adesso
suoneranno un'unica armonia un'unica
sinfonia e questa sinfonia ha un nome si
chiama bryce land il nostro centro
no profit ha sede nel comune di milo una
struttura molto grande si estende su di
un parco grande 48 mila metri quadrati
quattro edifici 1.600 metri quadrati di
copertura un posto meraviglioso che le
figlie della carità ci hanno messo a
disposizione gratuitamente
innamorata delle attività che svolgiamo
tutto quello che ci piacciamo
all'interno sì perché là dentro ci
prendiamo cura delle persone che hanno
un problema reale
il non vedente chissà che diventeranno
un vedente e nel farlo sviluppiamo tanta
tecnologia non soltanto quella che vi ho
raccontato oggi quella è una delle tante
ad esempio giusto per citarne qualcuno
non voglio fare l'intero elenco redais
un sistema che permette di effettuare il
test del riflesso rosso più di un bimbo
utilizzando solo uno smartphone android
lo stiamo sperimentando adesso ho ancora
leonardo un ausilio che permette di
dirigere un'orchestra fatta solo da
persone con disabilità visiva bisogna
dissi ai un caschetto col quale stiamo
studiando l'attività elettrica della
corteccia visiva o ancora pose da un 2.0
un sistema che permette di guidare un
non vedente nuotatore in acqua e tante
tante altre attività sociali cliniche
ricerca medica biomedica e
bioinformatica di iceland è un posto
dove tante persone tanti professionisti
tanti volontari tanti studenti o ex
studenti persone con competenze più
disparate siamo uniti da un'unica grande
convinzione e il lavoro di gruppo è
l'armonia che fa la differenza
e tutto questo è di ice
[Musica]
[Applauso]